so Rick's are coming back today part two
of learning in equilibrium I'm going to
talk about extensive form games let's
remind you briefly this is how we model
games with sequential multiple moves and
the shift is that now the strategies
will no longer be actions like rock or
or heads it will be complete contingent
plans that specify the action to be
taken and every information set in the
game tree so these are strategies are
called complete contingent plans you
hand this off to a to an agent or
computer would play the game for you um
so the action you play it an information
set can depend on what's happened before
so the actions can depend on other
player's actions an extensive form game
but we can think of all the players are
simultaneously choosing strategies
before the game is played okay and it's
known given an extensive form and I have
a couple here just remind you what they
look like we can associate it a unique
strategic form instead of strategies to
use extend so firm
once we do that the definition of Nash
equilibrium applies verbatim without any
change at all it's just a Nash
equilibrium is a strategy profile such
that no player can increase their payoff
by changing their strategy holding fix
to strategy everyone else but the
definition was perfectly well defined
consistent it's less satisfactory and
extensive form games for two reasons one
of which you probably already have heard
about in one of it you might not have so
the familiar problem is that Nash
equilibrium does not incorporate
predictions based on knowledge of
opponents payoff functions okay so this
is what led to developments of so called
equilibrium refinements these are things
that take the set of Nash equilibria
discard some and keep the others in the
earliest and best known of these is sub
game perfect equilibrium which I was
told most of you will have heard of um
so this is an important issue it's a
known issue i'm going to suppress it
most of us talk the end i'll come back
to a bit of how to add the same sort of
our fog inul to what i want to talk
about which is that nash equilibrium and
it's refinements describe situations
where players no more than is is is
guaranteed by most learning processes
and in some cases play can converge to a
self confirming equilibrium that's not
Nash and remember the result last time
these fictitious play tag processes if
play converged it was to a Nash
equilibrium whole issues would it
converge well now there's a different
question what might play converge to of
course so as I said last time the effect
of any learning process depends on what
players get to see when they play the
game and I'm going to assume that each
time players play the game they see at
most a terminal node of the game so what
does that mean the terminal node is the
end node there's an extensive form
between player one and player two if
player one goes left we end up here
player 1 does not get to see what player
2 would have done had player 1 given her
the move okay so you'll players only
Seaver terminal node
of the game don't see what ponents would
have done that means that we think about
players playing this game repeatedly and
learning they've got an exploration
exploitation trade off player one might
say well gee I think left is probably
the right thing I can get to you know
maybe player two is playing a and then
if I play a middle I could get three
maybe I would want to find out what
player 2 is doing by experimenting and
giving to the move sometime and seeing
what's going on on the other hand if
players choose not to do this
experimentation they get no data off
path play and so incorrect beliefs could
persist player 2 might be being really
nice and playing a player one might
think player 2 is playing be and so
player 1 would always play left briefly
I won't have time to develop this I'm
going to assume today that every time
the game is played players see the
resulting terminal node where we end up
at the ends of a tree I think it's hard
to imagine how you'd see more than that
but there's many cases where it's
interesting to intensive all to think
players see less than that for example
in a first price sealed bid auction the
terminal node is the complete vector of
everyone's bids and if it's an
incomplete information auction the
terminal node is everyone's value and
you might suppose might think when
people play the game they see less than
this that all they see is is it's a
partition of a terminal nodes maybe you
just see the winning bid okay so that's
that that's core serve in the terminal
node less information and i will talk a
bit about this at the literals talk not
for now something that's interesting it
has not been much developed in the
learning gains literature agents might
observe the outcomes have matched it
might observe the outcomes of play and
other matches so player 1 plays
you know it's a bit afraid in place owl
but she has a friend who's playing the
same game and her friend plays arch in
so you could get some word of mouth or
some some social learning there's a
literature on social learning and
economics it's mostly about technology
adoption things like that it hasn't been
applied to this kind of learning and
games it probably should be so questions
in this literature what kinds of
outcomes can be steady states of
learning processes well depends of a
learning process so there's different
answers this self confirming equilibrium
I already alluded to a refinement called
rationalize abul self confirming maybe
nash sub game perfect etc now as I said
some sort of experimentation seems
needed to rule out convergence to a non
Nash outcome because otherwise people
have wrong beliefs how much of its off
path play is needed for each equilibrium
concept and different equilibrium
concepts implicitly demand different
amounts of information about off pass
play that's the question okay ha excuse
me I should that be good I I've added
some place way too late so fix a
strategy profile we have a path of play
that's the information sets that are
reached with positive probability and
off path is anything that given this
profile should never happen
so you know i'll be using that term a
lot that's that's that it's good to know
what that means um so we how much
experimentation is needed so we should
break down in two bits how much
information is needed which information
sets much must believe be correct and
what kind of experimentation rules will
give that information so it's a two-part
expansion of a question and finally how
much off path play will actually occur
in various models how much will people
experiment give you an overview of the
literature the first wave of papers on
this on methodologically what are called
bounded lee rational learning because
they wrote down learning rules they
didn't derive them from anything and in
particular the the key issue is how much
do people experiment and that was
hardwired into these papers ok so what
crap sanai did in 88 we looked at a
belief based model in the spirit of
fictitious play players have beliefs and
optimize given beliefs except that we
imposed the condition that people
experiment at rate 1 over T cables a
lower bound on the probability of any
action at any information set that
shrinks to zero at rate 1 over T
why this this rate this rate which is
enough experimentation to rule out
convergence to any non Nash outcome
provided beliefs are asymptotically
empirical in a sense i defined yesterday
that beliefs converge to the data in
large data sets why is that okay for
Nash equilibrium you know we don't need
every player to have correct beliefs um
for example if i did some complicated
tree like this 1 2 3 and we have it
we're asking is this a Nash equilibrium
for player 1 to play here well one has
to correctly forecast what to is doing
here to might miss forecast what tree is
doing that's okay Nash equilibrium does
not impose any constraints on the play
of 2 so all we need in this game is for
player if we wanted to say is this Nash
we need to make sure one knows what to
is doing okay well more generally it we
want to have correct beliefs it's quote
relevant information sets which we
define formally but informally the idea
is user information sets we fix the path
of play suppose any one player
unilaterally deviated what notes could
be reached if only a given player
deviates those are the relevant
information sets okay and with this sort
of experimentation every one of these
relevant information sets is in fact
reached innocently often why well
because we have a sum of up with a
missing equals but because the sum one
over T is what it's infinite and so we
can appeal to 0 1 law and say well this
happens infinitely often so people get
an infinite data set and bassam tonic
empiricism with an infinite data set
your beliefs are correct okay so this is
enough experimentation so they'll have
large numbers and s effect empiricism
believes that the if play converges
beliefs at the relevant information sets
are correct that's not to say that
believes that every
information set are correct why because
the sum over one or T squared is finite
so we don't have a zero one law there so
the rifle is here is it ah let me
explain this picture okay so suppose our
limit outcome is one is one thinks a is
optically it's mostly playing a
experiments with be with one over T to
thinks d is optimal mostly plays d but
we can straight him to experiment with
see with one over T suppose that this
behavior stabilizes or repeats and
repeats and repeats okay well one is
going to play be instantly often one
will learn what to is doing so it better
be if this is stable that a is the best
response when two plays d ok we'll to
learn what three is doing well three
years Reese with public one over T
Square so that's and that's why it's
relevant in this two-stage game and if
we had three stages you know we'd have T
cubed ok so now it's obvious fix here if
we wanted the rule that guaranteed this
is reached infinitely often make this
root T now we're good if we had a game
of length 3 make a cube root of T so for
any fixed length game we can cook up a
rule that makes everything be reached
infinitely often but your your point is
I want
consistent with behavior only need to go
one level past for Nash equilibrium so
the poise that what I'm asserting here
is two things first of all with this
rule any player on the path of play
learns what would happen if he
unilaterally deviated gets claim one
claim to that property is sufficient to
mean that if this wasn't Nash we
couldn't converge to it if it's not Nash
it has to be that one could gain by
deviating and one knows what's going on
that's claimed to claim 3 we could still
converge them it's not sub game perfect
say cuz sub-game perfection we need
three to optimize for two to know what
three is doing and tues not getting
enough data about three so it's rule is
enough for Nash it's not enough for a
stronger concept sure it's good question
um so okay please is one of the TV best
so what's your criterion so if you have
time average payoffs it doesn't you know
you can put in anything that goes to
zero and you're good um it's a fair
question so where did this come from and
I'm a bit i'm going to may not give you
the kind of answer you would like but my
kind of answer is about to come okay so
this this this example is net not to
tell you one over T is the answer this
is saying it raises the question of how
much experimentation people will do and
it shows how it matters right one of our
team one of our root tea were different
in that example something that matters
for you know economists maybe more than
for you guys if we think of our guys as
rational actors Maximus utility they're
not going to randomize at all so 1 over
2 which is it's also extraneous this is
this is you know this is all crazy talk
if you're have a non perturb utility
function you're going to have
deterministic optimum so you know
perhaps when I wrote this paper in 88
it's unpublished with this version
because we got cold feet at the time you
know that the climate was not very good
for models that weren't at least close
to being optimal and we weren't even
nesting up in the play so he got sweet
through that model out and did something
else again tom dooley rational but at
least nested
terminus to experimentation so maybe
that was a mistake 15 years but this is
what we did now if people don't
experiment at all there's no data and
obviously we shouldn't expect Nash we
expect this self confirming concept and
there's different papers that have shown
that and before us any more about
dynamics i'm going to digress and just
look at equilibrium concept so get the
dynamics we're going to look at a game
I'm going to define something called
self confirming equilibrium so we have a
game you know with players it's finite
nodes index by X information sets or H
terminal nodes or Z payoff functions
depend only have a terminal node the set
of pure strategies you know player I is
si there might be a sick astok move by
nature if so we'll put in as a player
you can give her strategy each strategy
profile s determines a distribution over
terminal nodes if I tell you what people
are doing I can just multiply out the
tree and see we end up with a quarter
probability here quarter probably there
etc players know the extensive form
except they might not know the
distribution of nature's move so it's
rid of two you know variants of a
concept either you know the distribution
which is the standards are common prior
distribution or you don't in which case
we treat nature like a player with a
fixed move and people have to learn
nature's play from their data beliefs
for player I or just a measure over the
opponent's strategy profiles
for a fixed strategy profile I can using
Koontz theorem identify an equivalent
behavior strategy which is the play at
each information set if people aren't
familiar with this this language I'll
say that a player's beliefs are correct
at a given information set if they
remember beliefs are on this big space
overall opponent strategies some subset
of your opponent strategies you know has
is doing some sets that in this big
space corresponds to the case where you
believe your opponent's at information
set 7 or acts are doing what they're
actually doing so if your your beliefs
assigned probably 12 this lower
dimensional space that coincides with
what the player is doing information set
7 will say your release are correct and
information sets of it because that's
that's the idea of beliefs being correct
at information set police are correct
full stop if the corrected every
information set you might have correct
beliefs at one information set and not
at another and a strategy profile sigma
is the self confirming equilibrium if
for every player I and for every pure
strategy SI that player eyes Sigma I
gives positive probability we can find
beliefs mui with two properties SI is
the best response to the beliefs just
like an ash you're maximizing your
payoff given what you think and your
belief is correct at every information
set H that actually happens when you
play si so we could strengthen this to
say your beliefs are correct at every H
pull stop and we have a definition of
Nash best reply to beliefs beliefs are
right so we're weakening Nash your
beliefs could be wrong at some
information sets so things to note if we
have a one-shot simultaneous move game
okay well then each player is one
information set it's always reached so
there are no off path information sets
so this condition is equivalent to the
usual Nash condition we have Nash
equilibrium so that's
reduction on the other thing that I want
you to stop and notice is the order of
quantifiers each si in the support of
Sigma I could possibly be justified by a
different belief so we're not assigning
a single belief to player I so it's not
that we think player is schizophrenic
multiple personalities rather the reason
for this is remember the story about
learning is a big population we're
matching people we think there's really
many agents in the role of each player
there's many player ones and many player
two's some player one's not in this game
might always play left and never see
what player 2 is doing and of wrong
beliefs other player ones might play say
right all the time and learn what player
2 is doing so different player ones have
different beliefs if they're playing
different things we can define a
restriction of its concept called
unitary self confirm equilibrium where
every agent in a given player role has
the same belief so it says for each s
that it says there is a belief new ivory
choice such as for all s eyes we flip
the quantifiers on the strategy and
belief that's a restriction there's some
related concepts in the literature that
are also unitary that I should at least
put it on the screen but I won't talk
about um I want to now talk I want to
know Ellis trait house itself confirming
equilibria differ from Nash equilibria
come I was actually expecting something
much more asked for consistence
20 strategies when they kind of lead to
the same information set so you can have
different beliefs and as much as it
involves different notes you reach in
the trick is it access well I'm not sure
but so let's um I want to think about
the case so here if player 1 plays left
we can agree that we can let player 1
have wrong beliefs here's that's what
I'm doing let me show you a bit about
what this concept does and then I'll
come talk about the learning foundations
how this relates to explicitly and that
maybe you'll be able to us on those
questions then when I get back to a
learning model okay so here's an example
where we have an outcome that's self
confirming and not Nash because two
players disagree about the play of a
third player so the outcome I want to
look at is where one goes across and two
goes across so we see is that big a
little a the strategy profile that
supports that is say one goes a 2 goes a
and 3 goes l because we won't see trees
play this is what happens we'll never
see threes play so it's self confirming
why one says I'm getting one now I could
go down what should player 1 believe
well let's have player 1 believe that
player 3 is playing right if one thinks
3 is playing right one thinks one is
more than 0 I'm happy playing across how
about player 2 2 says I can play across
and get one if I play down what do I get
let's have to believe that one places
left to says okay I'm happy I'll play
across so both people are optimizing
given their beliefs and these are self
confirming why self confirming says your
beliefs are consistent with your data no
one ever sees threes play so self
confirming says you can believe whatever
you want about player 3 and this could
arise from a Bayesian learning process
suppose initially player one thinks 3 is
playing right player 2 thinks 3 is
playing left they both play across they
get no data and then my process
say when you get no data you don't
update so why is that well one shouldn't
update for example if one's prior belief
about is that tues play and threes
player independent then seeing tues play
tells them nothing about Three's play no
reason to update and conversely so this
can be a stable point of a learning
process but it's not a Nash equilibrium
yeah why not well Nash equilibrium says
beliefs are correct well there's only
one way to be correct so whatever player
3 is doing if beliefs are correct player
1 and 2 have to have the same belief
about player 3 and you know if the wait
the three places on left is more than a
third one wants to go down if the weight
that pre places on a right is more than
the third two wants to go down we've got
to put wait more than a third somewhere
so we're not updating despite the fact
that we might get information that
others have different beliefs yes
exactly so that's that's that's exactly
right if you like I can discuss that
more but if now I want to allow for
heterogeneous beliefs which is actually
quite an important thing empirically i'm
not going to show you an empirically
important example i'ma show you the
simplest possible toy example of the
impact of Henry's beliefs there'll be no
unitary self confirming equilibrium
where half the time we see one go out
half the time one into a but it will be
a heterogeneous equilibrium okay so
suppose we see half the time one goes
out half a time up here
is unitary self confirming we need to a
given belief for player one if the
belief is that um to you know always
plays a all the ones go in and because
two is being reached self confirming
says you if it's a single player one who
is sometimes out sometimes giving to the
move play one would learn where to is
doing would want to go in however
suppose there's a lot of player ones
some of them think two is playing be and
those guys go out and then never see
anything the other ones think two is
playing a they go in and they're happy
that's a stable situation so this is a
really trivial situation but as I said
there's more complicated ones in many
game to your experiments look at the
data you are it's very hard to make
sense of a data if you require all the
people to have the same beliefs it may
get much easier with heterogeneous
beliefs yes if it's the so unit area is
all the people in the role have one
belief and the negation of that I'm
calling heterogenous this means there's
more than one belief in a given agent
role there is a probability as I do
implicitly I mean it's not part of the
construction city so if we go back to
the definition here's the definitions
for each SI there's a belief it's
unitary if I can flip the quantifiers if
it's I can't slip the quantifiers it's
not unitary so that's that's the
in this example no this is a Nash
equilibrium and this is what we're
seeing is a convex combination of Nash
equilibrium so some experimenters you
know confirm Nash equilibrium by saying
eighty-five percent my observations were
one of a Nash equilibrium you know but
if you have you know forty percent here
and forty percent there you've been
allowing for some noise you're
completely rejecting Nash equilibrium
because the set of national glue rooms
in are convex in more complicated games
we can get things outside of the convex
hull of Nash equilibria so easy to see
here we can get mixing we couldn't
before now in bed the mixing is some
stage now we can get different actions
being played empirically this is
particularly important of subjects have
doubts about other people's preferences
miss hard to forecast based on
preferences so as many experiments were
that are designed to make people think
about you know fairness or social type
of preferences in those settings the
experimenters don't know the dispersion
of preferences how should the subjects
never disputed preferences and they can
play differently okay how what factors
lead self confirmed a different from
Nash shown you heterogeneous beliefs can
make support outcomes at art Nash
correlated beliefs so I didn't draw an
example let me do is verbally imagine
the game where one can go in or you know
a or b a or b gives players two and
three to move and two and three place
simultaneously and we can write down
payoff such that for any independent
play of two and three one does not want
to go out but if two and three correlate
in the right way one wants to go out so
we can get an outcome that wouldn't be
supported by Nash that's supported by
correlation important thing about this
correlation here in this model players
know the extensive form there is no
correlating device so it's not that one
thinks two and three you're really
correlating it's rather a subjective
uncertainty example suppose player one
says I don't know what to entry are
doing either they're both playing heads
or they're both playing tails and I
don't know which that's not a products
measure player one thinks if only he
played in once he would
the truth which is not correlated but
the subjective uncertainty could be
correlated and that can deter a player
one from giving two and three the move
so that's that's a another channel and
the third channel I've already showed
you inconsistent believes that players
one and two might disagree about the
play of player three of course I can
only matter if both player one and
player 2 can cause player three to be
reached if player 1 and player to
disagree about player 3 only player 1
can give player 3 the move only player
one's beliefs count so so it turns out
that this list is exhaustive if you turn
off all these three channels your back
to nash I'm not going to please
yes head of a genius beliefs means that
a given play a role people have there's
more than one belief say in the player
ones so we have heterogenous beliefs in
a two-player game as I showed you
inconsistent beliefs is that consistency
condition is vacuous in a two-player
again only matters with three or more
players so yes they're different okay
let me state a related and simpler
theorem on instead of this one explain
it to you may have some independent
interest in showing what's going on let
H bar of s this is that's calling the
path of s the stretch information sets
reached with positive probability when s
is played and I'll say that a game has
observed deviate errs if for every
player and every pure strategy and every
deviation for player I as had I not si
if we can get to H when player I
unilaterally deviates and everyone else
sticks to us and we can't get to a jiff
no 1 deviates that's what this says so
we're in this set but not in that Center
we don't get there without a deviation
player I can make it happen then if
player I does not deviate no matter what
everyone else does we can't get there
what does that mean that means if we get
to this age if we thought people were
playing s and unexpectedly we get to
this H we know what happened player I
must have deviated only player i could
have made this happen player i didn't
deviate it couldn't have happened so
player i must have deviated okay games
of perfect information where every
information sets a singleton likes HS
have observed deviator 'he's as do all
multi-stage games with deserve actions
if you don't know what those are think
of repeated games with observed actions
repeated christmas alumnus observe
deviate errs every two player game with
perfect recall has observed deviate errs
because there's two players and someone
deviated and you didn't deviate yeah
it's not so many other suspects the
victims observed deviator turns out to
hold in most games in the economics
literature it didn't Holden in the horse
game because there if three got the move
maybe one did it may be too did it three
didn't know so i can define what
independent beliefs are each player's
beliefs about the player the others is a
product measure that's what you think
and the theorem is that in games with
observed deviate errs the outcome of any
independent unitary sup confirm
equilibrium is also the outcome of a
nash equilibrium so in this class of
games all we have to worry about is
correlation and heterogeneity
and not not Inquisition max distance II
because it's not possible because the
consistency was we both disagree about
the flavor third guy in fact that
doesn't matter so much in with deserved
deviate errs so and here's the idea of
the proof with unitary beliefs for every
player there is a belief we can say it's
player eyes believes the heterogeneous
not with unitary yes okay with
independent beliefs these beliefs
correspond to a mixed strategy profiles
let me stop on that for a second suppose
does a three-player game one is beliefs
about 2 and about three from koontz
theorem any mixed belief about 2
corresponds to a single strategy profile
for to any mix belief about 3
corresponds to a Mick strategy profile
for 3 the coons theorem is player by
player it's not the case any subjective
distribution over the joint play of 2
and 3 corresponds to a mixed strategy
profile for two and three because of
there might be correlation that you and
by definition emich strategy people mix
independently we assume independence now
this works we compute the [ __ ] map for
player 2 the crude map for player 3 take
the product and that's our strategy
profile observe deviate errs only one
players beliefs about played enough path
information set are relevant who there's
only one guy who can make this
information set happen ok so what we're
going to do is change the play at that
information set to match the belief of a
guy who could make it happen he was not
going to deviate play one was not going
to deviate if two did Action 7 let's
tell to to play action 7 now player ones
the set of constraint is fine one has
correct beliefs how about player 2's
optimization can straight you might
worry well the two is off the path and
Nash equilibrium it poses no constraints
on actions off the path so we're going
to change the play of people to get a
different profile with exactly the
outcome observing before and now it's
nash that's just a whirlwind discussion
of stuff from equilibrium
the nurse outcome yes and a shout come
in at the nash profile but the theorem
says that the outcome of any independent
unit area is the outcome and of those
outcome words are important because we
change the profile while keeping the
outcome fixed it's exactly right okay so
now we go back to learning dynamics and
maybe Tim move can you can reformulating
the question if it if it um comes up so
various learning models how itself
confirming is a long-run outcome so
after crepes and I threw out that model
with the whatever T experimentation we
did some boundary rational thing and
said that your asymptotically what we
might get to you know we could get to
any sub confirm equilibrium even then so
we weren't doing this randomization that
it was bounded Lee rational and so
economist don't you know don't like
bounding rational what sort of the the
most kosher constrain kind of economic
model it's maximizing expected discount
utility so to like the so I'm going to
tell you a bit about how to do it that
way so this is a paper with Slovenian
493 first I'll tell you what the
individual agents do and then I'll tell
you about the system and what the month
of theorem is so there's many agents in
the role of each player I and they
expect to play this game capital T times
that's called about the lifetime and
they try and maximize you have a
discounted some of prepared utilities
it's completely standard this is just a
normalizing constant so I change T in
delta's its units don't change each time
the game is played agent observes only
the terminal node
as in fictitious play the agent believes
they face a fixed time invariant
distribution of opponents play I think
their drawers are exchangeable they
aren't sure what the distribution
opponents play is the aggregate we're
not going to make the deer clay
assumption would be more general the
prior is anything that's non doctrine
error meaning it's represented by a
continuous density function that's
strictly positive except we let it go to
zero at the endpoints why do we bother
like is there at the end points because
we like to nest dura clay priors and
those go to zero at the end points and
then you update using Bayes rule non
doctrinaire prior implies non
doctrinaire posterior mechanically so we
agent you know it has a bunch of signals
and actions if it is a discounted
dynamic programming problem I'm not
going to solve it for you I'm just going
to assert a solution exists fire to rise
in discounting it's pretty plain vanilla
find it actions so take a solution for
each agent without loss of generality
the solution can be deterministic agents
don't mix so that's for now I'll cut off
to say more about the agents at some
point but then we keep on developing the
model let's talk about the aggregate
model with everybody at once so I'm
assume there's a unit mass of agents in
each population I'm going to assume a
doubly infinite sequence of time period
so i'm not going to have initial
condition its time going to start at
minus infinity and go forwards the
overlapping generations this is
something common in economics so this is
unit mass of players so if T is to half
of them are old and half are new and
each day you know the old people leave
and a new cohort comes in or think of
you know this term to start it's at
equals force every year the students
graduate and freshmen come in every
period agents are randomly and
independently matched with people from
the other populations and a three-player
game we could make pairs of one two and
three so the probability of meeting an
agent particular age is their share in
the population we have two equals four
you have a one-quarter chance of being
paired with a freshman
agents don't observe the ages or past
experiences of their opponents and all
you observe is the sequence of terminal
nodes of your games and for simplicity
I'm assume each population as a common
prior so all the player ones have the
same prior I don't need that I could add
a subscript and and complicate that up
okay so what is the state of a system
well at any time there's some freshman
they've seen nothing no blank slates
they're sophomores and you know some
took chemistry some took biology some
liked it some didn't so we have the the
histories people have had in there for
years and and we have the masses of
people in each history that's the state
of a system and
given this state and given these rules
people have which is what you strategy
you have when you're history has been
this what do you do next year we can
compute what happens next period that's
a continuous map so it's got a fixed
point upshot the system has steady
States okay and my next step is to
characterize the steady States that's
side note the steady state thing might
be a little surprising you know
fictitious play is stochastic it bounces
around and non-stationary you only get
towards equilibrium limit so we you know
asymptotically we could talk about these
steady states which tribe longer here we
never got there this system actually has
steady States okay what's going on it's
some modeling tricks that let us have
steady States and there's two modeling
tricks okay assistance deterministic the
individual play is stochastic where the
noise go the continuum assumption we
wash it out with the continuum okay now
fictitious play is not autonomous the
time steps are getting is you know the
more data you have the slower you
updates so so it's this system
stationary it has a steady state how is
a stationary well we have people
learning so that's what's pushing time
steps down if you want have a steady
state and informations flowing and
information has to flow out and these
fix lifetimes are away for information
to flow out or equivalently number i
said people leave we could mind wipe
them we could keep the students forever
exam be students and every four years
mind wipe them and they start again
that's that's so that's it that's that's
what's going on here so what are the
steady states well for lifetime equals
one it's really easy to see what they
are its people have a prior to show up
play a best response and leave game over
give it's really kind of boring Lily
driven by the prior an interesting thing
that I have nothing to say about I would
like to know more is what happens if a
lifetime is intermediate like four or 10
he says it's interesting when t is for t
is 10 but some people who've been around
for a while have learned the ropes
if some newbies and experienced guys you
know might want to distort their play to
take advantage of a newbie's no results
all the results are going to be the
limits of lifetime's are really long
which means there are hardly any newbies
that's everyone is lots of experience in
generations
it's a good question if we stop and
think this is separated so a question is
for 60 are there still steady states is
there a steady state for newbies and a
steady state for the age to people um is
I suspect that's the case I'd have to
stop and verify it then what are they i
have no idea but um yeah I mean I think
this well-mixed thing is more more
natural for my applications but there's
still in an interesting question okay
I'm going to tell you what the steady
states are like something else i'm not
going to tell you about that's an open
question you know in the static case i
could talk about these equilibrium is
stable or not we could head of the
two-dimensional system a four
dimensional system we look at a steady
state compute the eigenvalues and see
the ones that are unstable we can't
converge to so the way of both the
system right the state of a system is
the vectors of how many people of each
history the longer of a lifetime is the
bigger of a dimension of a system and
that sort of dimensionality problem has
kept us from doing any formal stability
checks so the we need some sort of clued
your work around to squish this down to
something finite dimensional to get
stability jason said a question or you
think you were actually in part answer
yet I just follow exactly the role that
these generations were playing and they
weren't in her to talk yesterday they
weren't and so there there's a reason
you introduced them reason I introduced
him was because it was I wanted to say
something about optimal experimentation
of people their vision that turns out to
be really hard to do in this slowing
down over time fictitious play like
system to just say something about the
optimal rules here i have a stationary
world and i brought in the the
information that bout of the generations
really just to be able to have a steady
state i could put my hand on as opposed
to saying steady states of these objects
off
t equals infinity so that's two
overlapping generations we were to have
the mind wipe to get steady States and
that's that's the that's the extent of
it it's also sort of a modeling device
economists are used to is used many
growth in macro models so it's but you
may see more in the about what it's
doing in the proof of this theorem any
limit I'm looking now a sequence of
steady states for longer and longer
lifetimes okay any such limit must be a
self confirming equilibrium and the
proof sketch has has 3 parts so if a
strategy has a positive share in the
limit it's got to be played a positive
fraction of a time by a positive
fraction of the population it if not
then it's shared would just be going
away well if a positive fraction two
people pay it a positive fraction of a
time they've got a big data set okay
most of the people who've played the
strategy many times have about the
correct beliefs why is that there's two
steps to this first the law of large
numbers in a big data set your data
looks like the theoretical distribution
secondly in a big data set your beliefs
look like the data why is that that's
true uniformly in a rate police converge
to a particular distribution at a rate
depends only on the sample size and not
on your data under this non doctrinaire
prior assumption and that's a result of
via conus and friedman it's a non
probabilistic results is calculus
yeah finally agents eventually stop
experimenting and play a myopic best
response to their beliefs if you're
familiar with you know the Bandit
literature of the gettin's index for
discounted very programming this is just
sort of be expected you know eventually
you have enough data you think I'm not
going to learn much more from one more
pull of your arm so I I'm going to play
with myopic Lee optimal in the long run
there's a small complication here we
can't just point to get ins and be done
because agents doe the extensive form of
the game so that means you might have a
sample that you know is screwy and even
though you played an action many times
you might still think I'm going to learn
a ton if i only played it once more that
can't happen usual bandit world well but
those are screwy samples and they
shouldn't happen often okay and that's
it it's the sort of have a picture of us
here and suppose that the data is a
quarter of a time left a a quarter of
time left be someone's been playing left
half a time and half the time right a so
one has never gotten to see three play
but when it's played right many times so
the usual story would be if I've played
right many times I think I won't learn
anything from playing right again but
here one knows that that he and two were
playing independently he thinks too is
mixing 5050 he thinks if only I play
right I'm going to glue with probably a
half i'll get to see what three is doing
and maybe it's really useful so one
should keep on playing right in contrast
to bandits but you know if to Willie is
playing independently of one this sample
shouldn't happen it's very unlikely so
that's why it's not important yeah I see
if you're like this second interpretive
victory for the equilibrium or is the
victory for
dynamic process itself hmm not
particularly i kind of like them both
and I was I don't know it's um i guess
if I had to pick between the two I pick
the equilibrium concept there are many
different dynamic models i could write
down to have this so the reason for this
one that's it isn't so much for the self
confirming result which is comparatively
easy the issue i raised at the start was
how much experiment that people do and
to put some discipline on that i said
how much experimenting will rational
guys do well if they're impatient they
don't experiment that's easy we're
previous theorem now that what happens
if they're patient I want to see what
happens discount factor goes to one okay
and this is where I use all this extra
assumptions and modeling tricks to
having steady states the outcome has to
be a Nash equilibrium outcome not
prophylaxis but big glib in the slides
and what we see will be Nash the outcome
okay as I said that was easy to prove
under one or two experimentation it's
not the model here okay now you might
think if people are patient without
experiment every information set that's
false and proof in a later paper I'm may
not have time to tell you about as well
as yes well theoretically so Pyrrhic Lee
have no idea I'll talk about the period
at the end so moreover so from giddens
you might think what people are patient
they'll take all their actions a bunch
maybe not one over T but they'll take
them as some fraction of a time and we
could do something even that is wrong
okay and that's wrong a thing for an
interesting reason matter how patient
you are a player in the path of play
might never play certain actions and
that comes back to the fact that players
know the extensive form so it's not an
independent armed bandit it's a
correlated armed bandit so consider this
game your one goes left gets too
if one goes em and two plays a one is
happening gets three if one goes em and
two plays be one is really unhappy loses
a ton if one place are gets one for sure
suppose one thinks well probably too is
playing be maybe two is playing a what
should one do okay if wants impatient to
stick here suppose one is patient okay
it's worth finding out what's happening
well the reason one wants to experiment
is maybe two plays a but if you don't
know two is doing you don't want to play
middle because that's really risky what
you want to do is play right see what to
is doing and then either play middle or
play left so you would never experiment
with em because this is just a better
experiment
as in the final as an aside I won't
develop this the people who are familiar
with corporate were tens and iterated
the for induction arguments this shows
none of those arguments Fisher because
too weakly dominates one so corporate
Martin's would say player one should
never play right and the two ever gets
to move to should think it's middle and
play a weave exactly the opposite
conclusion here okay so what do we do we
couldn't we didn't want to say people
play each action in Philly often they
don't we didn't want to characterize
self a rule we did use an indirect
argument in the steady state most people
who use a strategy do because it
maximizes their current payoff if
they've played it many times but don't
expect to learn more ya lo option value
at least for most histories as saying
these are unlikely if the limits not a
Nash equilibrium that means there's
something being played by someone that's
not optimal so there's something that's
better and will show but this better
thing has a non-vanishing option value
so if you're patient enough you would
use it and that contradicts this
assumption that you wouldn't use it so
again the proof is on option values
without explicitly characterizing the
the rules conclusion is patient players
experiment enough to rule out anything
that's not Nash that doesn't say that
every Nash equilibrium is the limit of
steady states okay and we looked at this
in a game of perfect information with
independent beliefs independent beliefs
and pert information makes
characterizing the optimal rules much
simpler because now it's not a multi not
a correlate bandit with perfect
information independent beliefs the only
reason to play in action is if you think
it's good you don't take the action
hoping to learn about the path to a
different action and we can show that
for some non doctrinaire priors matter
how patient you are people off the path
of play don't experiment
why not we inferiorly patient if you're
hardly ever reached right there's the
winch you take an action it doesn't help
you now to get information depends on
how much the information will help you
when you use it and when you get to use
it if you don't get to use it for a
really long time it's not so helpful it
said no it says you don't get all Nash
equilibria it says we can rule out some
Nash equilibria and I can tell you
exactly so in this class of games we can
have a the converse characterization the
first time said it had to be Nash if
you're patient and I'll state the
Thurman come back that these are the
what you will get if people are patient
we can get for sure is these sub game
confirmed Nash equilibrium which is a
subset of Nash and what is it I'm here
say a node is one step off the path of a
strategy profile if it's not reached
under the profile so it's off the path
but it's the immediate successor of are
known that is reached so one single
deviation would make it reach and a
profile as a sub game confirmed Nash if
it's nash and also in each sub game
beginning one step off the play of the
path the restriction of the profile to
that sub game is self confirming so it's
a very small strengthening of Nash
equilibrium let's get some things and
just show an example this is a
three-player game the unique sub game
perfect equilibrium three passes two
beats 1 so 2 says all paths cuz two
beats 1 so 3 says all paths because two
beats 1 so sub game perfect equilibrium
pass pass pass but drop drop pass is sub
game confirmed so one drops believing
the two drops and that's correct two is
dropping so when is
before casting the two is going to drops
believing three drops three impact
passes so tues beliefs are wrong so the
place starting here is not Nash but it's
self confirming to is dropping believing
that three is dropping and yeah so again
we aren't getting correct beliefs one
step off the path the two it gets passed
to but so rarely the two does not choose
to experiment so two gets passed to
enough that one learns tues play but
that too never gives three the moves so
two never learns threes play too as
reach so rarely it's not optimal for two
to ever give three to move is that's
theory and now some question about
empirics so how much patience
experimentation should we actually
expect well the discount factors and
continuation probabilities any lab
setting it's honestly bounded away from
one we're not going to be able to play
the game is forever so question for
thought I have no answer in what field
settings to very high discount factors
and lots of experimentation seem
plausible versus not and also to what
extent can something I didn't model word
of mouth and social learning or
historical records give extra
information so even though no one player
experiments may be an aggregate
information these are important open
questions that aren't known to quit not
engage in triage so I could either talk
about the effect of how to add in the ID
the people that pay up information let
me do that find out just when I two
topics I just I just arbitrarily picked
one so so far the only restrictions on
beliefs was they had to match your data
didn't try to model the idea you had
some prior idea oh gee my my opponent
really likes chocolate I think they can
order chocolate at this restaurant ever
been in this restaurant with them but
they always ordered chocolate i think
they're getting chocolate
we can add in that restriction we can
add into self confirming the idea that
people have some path information and
that fits with some data all are going
to have time to tell you the unitary
version of this which all the player
ones have the same beliefs which is
called rationalize will soften from
equilibrium okay there's a paper with
kamata who's at haas here at Berkeley
that extends this but I won't talk about
it so this condition is going to impose
some off path optimality based on
players knowing other players payoffs
and the formal definition is maybe not
so interesting and a lot of game theory
really proceeds by examples so let me
not give you definition we give you an
example where I will informally as a
definition and I think that'll be more
efficient and easier to remember this
game sort of it gets a strange looking
game it's not a multi-stage game with
deserved actions so small up big up is a
Nash equilibrium outcome sorry op op is
Nash one goes up three goals episode 22
never plays that that's consistent with
Nash seeing that therefore its self
confirming but it's not rational self
confirming even I even told you what
this is I'm going to say it's the idea
that players know each other's payoffs
and they know other players observation
structures and let me explain what's
going on so intuitively this is
happening all the time then one sees it
happening all the time one knows the two
of seeing it happening all the time so
one knows the two knows that three is
playing up
and one knows to spare function by
assumption so one says I if I gave to
the move what would to do two could get
one but since two knows three is playing
up to play and get you so so this is an
example so the combination of the PF
information and self confirming has this
collusion stronger my just the
intersection over two constraints so
deep it so this is not a ration it is
Nash but it's not this ration Liza
beliefs of confirming thing um good
question and the answer is yes and
that's not a consequence a anything I
have shown you but um every sequential
equilibrium needs this definition those
exist so that's um that's right okay one
last example well they said did i do
another example now or the typical
situation no I'm saying this is a
superset of its refinement of self
confirming it's a superset of sequential
she saying does it exist while
sequential exist so this exists this is
much bigger than sequential more with
work with kamata I will skip arm briefly
very briefly maybe not solutions for
this crowd economists are very into
behavioral game theory people making
mistakes mistakes and inference so as a
literature that combines self confirming
with inference mistakes so far our guys
are like doing things
pretty right so the paper seducing game
theory which have led to some interest
in models of learning games where the
players models are misspecified people
have the wrong model of the world not
because we think it's a good thing to do
because some behavioral evidence looks
like people are misspecified that they
think their opponents plays independent
of our type when it depends ever type
okay you know their prior rules out the
true states of the world so it's visit a
literature on this which i think is
interesting it's it's in development and
it's actually two people at Berkeley who
are linked to this so you should know
about arm so one is Philips track who
maybe is there use it berkeley economics
and if you're interested in hearing more
about you know learning with
misspecified models he'll be around all
semester and also damian pues el in
berkeley economics is doing some work on
this learning in games with me specified
models so if that's an interesting
interesting thing for you you have to to
experts here so let me close with some
open questions and problems so i told
you this very whirlwind i stated this
result for sub game confirmed
equilibrium which characterizes what
happens with patient rational learners
but that result i managed to avoid
telling you the only holds four they're
called simple games these are games the
perfect information or each player moves
up most once on any path open question
what happens in vigor classes of games
we don't know i mentioned this open
question about modeling learning and
mixed pools of experienced and novice
players but trick there's to find some
interesting special cases in domains
something i didn't talk about at all you
know which you might have asked about
model people extrapolate between similar
games so implicitly and games framework
people aren't playing repeated game they
play whatever the game is over and over
with different people which we can do in
the lab and you can ask how often people
play these same game not many times
my answer is well it depends on how
demanding a notion of the same game you
have and at a metaphysical stands for
back to the basic problem of inference
right if if the day is different than
yesterday you can't learn anything you
have to assume something in the past is
like today to learn anything now we can
be a little less glib and stay in game
so when do you extrapolate from one game
to another it's tight on a different day
that it gets a different person but if
you play a game with one Berkeley
undergraduate do you use that experience
to help you against a different Berkeley
undergraduate things like that
intuitively I think people do problem is
we have no real hand on how people do in
any sort of results on extrapolation
depend on the details of the
extrapolation process I don't have any
good good conditions I pride occasions
look at the psych literature on this and
gotten got nothing useful so I mentioned
yesterday stochastic choice I perturb
the exact best response functions with
this regularizer nonlinear term to make
things to cast ick a fair question why
not do that here if I do that here and
the stochastic terms are by the way from
zero that asymptotically all my
experimentation problems go away because
the the noise will make everything hit
on the other hand if the only time you
play one of these actions is when the
noise term makes you that could be very
rare so that's a changes the question
from what happens that's antara CLE to
what happens it's a notion of
intermediate run so my conjecture would
be that in this sort of world we would
eventually you know get correct beliefs
that every information set with enough
time and in bounded noise will
eventually see everything if play
converges learn everything it may take a
long time and I think self confirming
could still come up as a sort of
intermediate term you quickly learn the
path it takes much longer to learn
what's happening farther down the tree
implications of misspecified models and
decision problems and games okay so I
mentioned this this this work with
Philip so thank you very much